l'histoire d'amour entre astrazeneca et
l'union européenne n'a jamais été
sereine même si aujourd'hui les tensions
se sont apaisées le vieux continent va
se retrouver ironie de l'histoire avec
un trop plein de doses un paradoxe quand
on se souvient qu'il ya six mois à
bruxelles s'apitoyer sur son sort
déplorant le retard des 120 millions de
doses promises par le laboratoire
anglo-suédois seuls 30 millions avait
été livré lors du premier trimestre 2011
21 un manquement qui avait provoqué la
colère d'ursula von garnier
je pense qu'il est clair pour
l'entreprise que tout d'abord elle doit
rattraper son retard honoré le contrat
qu'elle a conclu avec les états
européens membres avant de pouvoir
commencer à exporter exporter des
vaccins
menacé de poursuites devant la cour
européenne de justice puis confronté à
des hésitations de l'agencé européenne
du médicament sur l'innocuité du vaccin
soupçonné d' accroître les risques de
formation de caillots sanguins
le laboratoire était sous pression la
conséquence directe c'est que le doute
s'est installé chez une majeure partie
de la population européenne et notamment
en france où la plupart des concernés
refusent désormais de se faire inoculer
le sérum produit par astrazeneca en juin
dernier le vaccin n'est pratiquement
plus administrer au stand l'hexagone
résultat un million six cent cinquante
mille doses sont actuellement en stock
dans le détail huit cent mille chez les
professionnels de ville à 47 milles au
sein des congélo porter et 8 110 milles
au niveau du stock national de sécurité
un stock qui risque de vite se périmer à
savoir que depuis le début de la
campagne de vaccination à près de 250
mille doses de vaccin astrazeneca ont
été jetés un fiasco et pourtant la
france a signé aux côtés de l'union
européenne début septembre un nouveau
contrat avec le laboratoire
anglo-suédois près de 20 millions de
doses devraient arriver d'ici mars 2022
pourquoi faire c'est la question qu'on
peut se poser à l'exception de quelques
pays d'europe centrale et notamment de
la bulgarie qui avaient beaucoup parier
sur le vaccin russe qui n'est jamais
arrivé l'essentiel de ces doses
devraient être versés aux 10 positif
kovacs une très bonne idée sur le papier
qui vient conforter le désir d' emmanuel
macron le chef de l'état a annoncé
vouloir doubler ses livraisons à kovacs
pour les porter à terme à 120 millions
essentiellement des doses d'astrazeneca
vous l'aurez compris car la france sur
ses promesses a beaucoup de retard du
coup l'exécutif veut se débarrasser de
ce surplus encombrants en le distribuant
à ceux qui en ont le plus besoin seul
problème c'est que les pays bénéficiant
de ce programme ne sont pas forcément
rassuré par l'efficacité du vaccin
astrazeneca tout du mois sa population
le malawi ou encore le soudan par
exemple ont dû renvoyer ou détruire des
doses de vaccin astrazeneca car il
n'était pas en mesure de les administrer
avant leur expiration hormis les
problèmes logistiques principal enjeu de
la vaccination dans les pays à faible
revenu la méfiance de la population
accentué l'hésitation vaccinale
l'urgence est bien là puisque dans les
pays les plus pauvres du globe à peine 2
% de la population a été vaccinée